non
bonjour et bienvenue au coeur du
parlement européen à bruxelles pour
l'émission europe hebdo cette semaine on
s'intéresse à l'illettrisme ce fléau
caché touche près d'un européen sur sept
et notamment les pays en crise reportage
au portugal mais tout de suite la
question d'actualité l'europe est-elle
projet m
en europe les polémiques se suivent et
se ressemblent après l' agence
européenne du médicament et la sphère
médiator c'est au tour de l'agencé de
sécurité des aliments d'être accusé de
collusion avec les producteurs
d'organismes génétiquement modifiés
la faute à l'avis rendu sur l'étude du
professeur séralini et la toxicité des
ogm en septembre dernier son laboratoire
met les pieds dans le plat tumeur
mammaire nécrose du foie inflammation
rénale mortalité prématurée des rongeurs
les ogm serait mauvais pour la santé
sans blague mais l'étude et controversé
et les critiques pleuvent mauvaise foi
et fautes professionnelles pour séralini
qui voit la main mise des producteurs
sur les scientifiques c'est la guerre de
position ils y allaient pour et il y
aller contre jusqu'aux autorités
sanitaires qui une à une des montes la
méthodologie utilisée par le laboratoire
sauf que ces agences sont régulièrement
pointés du doigt pour leur liens
incestueux avec les industriels pour
preuve la présidente de l' agence de
sécurité des aliments a quitté ses
fonctions il ya quelques mois pour
prendre la tête du lobby de l'industrie
agro alimentaire
alors bruxelles
projet
alors nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
michèle rivasi bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne française vous êtes du groupe
des verts on pose une question
volontairement provocante mais ce qu'on
peut dire que bruxelles et en
l'occurrence donc la commission
européenne serait selon vous projet m
bah écoutez la commission oui et projet
m par contre c'est pour remédier à cela
comment vous commandez parce que
plusieurs fois ils ont autorisé
justement du maïs
transgénique
et puis on s'aperçoit que il n'y avait
pas les études qui allait de pair c'est
pour ça qu'avec un certain nombre de
députés par rapport à l'étude de ces
rallyes n'est que vous avez mentionné
dans votre reportage on a dit il ya
quand même des choses qui vont pas
lagence l'efsa si vous voyez c'est l'
agence qui dit oui ou non est ce que les
études sont conformes par rapport à un
cahier des charges mais ce cahier des
charges ne va pas puisque on n'a pas des
études sur le long terme oui c'est sur
trois mois ou à la limite bon c'est 90
jours mais c'est même pas obligatoire
après lorsqu'on veut avoir toutes les
données faites par les industriels qui
demandent l'autorisation elles ne sont
pas publiques on les a pas sur internet
donc on a profité de ça pour dire quelle
que soit l'étude séralini de toute façon
elles m'ont des dysfonctionnements sur
le protocole employé par la chance c'est
une boîte et du doigt pour bien
comprendre c'est un manque de
transparence mais l'étude du professeur
séralini dont vous parlez là où il
s'agissait des rats avec cette humeur a
été je dirais pas unanimement mais elle
a été en tout cas beaucoup critiqué y
compris effectivement par les autorités
européennes donc est ce que ça veut dire
que sur le fond
l'europe et je reviens à ma question
président propres ogm ou des non c'est
juste un manque de transparence dans la
façon de faire varier deux choses
d'abord l'europe et projet m vous savez
qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya plein de
maïs par exemple où les états ne sont
pas d'accord pour donner l'autorisation
or s'il n'ya pas l'unanimité c'est la
commission qui décide et à l'heure
actuelle il ya à peu près 7
si vous voulez maïs qui sont en cours
d'autorisation
c'est la commission qui dit oui on va
les autoriser bon ça c'est une première
chose après la deuxième chose c'est
qu'ils donnent l'autorisation de mise
sur le marché c'est une agence sanitaire
qui s'appelle l'efsa et suite à l'étude
de ces relais ni qualité très fortement
critiquée ça a quand même mis en
évidence qu'il ya des dysfonctionnements
sur la façon dont on autorise ces maïs
ou soja ou où cette pomme de terre par
exemple qui peut être en génie c'est ça
qui va pas c'est qu'il n'est pas normal
qu'on étudie ça que sur une laps de
temps trop court il n'est pas normal que
tout le monde n'ait pas accès aux
données il n'est pas normal que toutes
les études soient faites par
l'industriel pour autoriser si
l'industriel cache des données et bien
c'est très difficile pour les
expériences dépendante de le voir et en
même temps lève ça a été plusieurs fois
attaqué conflit d'intérêts avec
l'association la présidente de l'efsa a
démissionné avant l'été dernier
justement parce qu'elle était on va dire
soupçonné de conflit d'intérêts et juste
après cette démission elle a été
travaillé dans le principal lobby des
ogm ça c'était il ya quelques mois
aujourd'hui ce que vous diriez que le
ménage a été fait à l'efsa écoutez le
ménage est en cours parce que en tant
que député européen on peut ne plus
voter les subventions
c'est ce qu'on a fait récemment mais je
dis que tous les conflits sont pas
réglés toutes les agences que se soit
l'agencé européenne des médicaments
le mae j'ai beaucoup travaillé où on a
fait démissionner des personnes qui
étaient en conflit d'intérêts que ça
soit l'efsa qui a un rôle essentiel sur
les ogm comme sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens
voyez comme sur toutes les substances
chimiques qui peuvent le toucher et bien
c'est pas clair il ya encore trop de
conflits d'intérêts et il faut faire le
ménage au niveau de ses agences alors
puisqu'on parle de démission il ya eu
aussi une démission à la commission
européenne du commissaire qui s'occupait
entre autres des affaires de santé et
des affaires liées aux ogm à nouveau
commissaire a été nommé ce que là aussi
vous n'avez que les choses vont dans le
bon sens alors écoutez cette affaire
daddy c'est le nom john dalli cern ont
des connaissances
moi j'avoue que ça me laisse perplexe
perplexe parce que
il ya une enquête effectivement par
l'olaf qui est l office si vous voulez
contrôler européen voilà la répression
des fraudes en quelque sorte et je
trouve que le président de la commission
est allé très vite en besogne c'est à
dire qui lui a demandé de démissionner
en dix minutes il devait démissionner et
quand on a regardé le rapport bien il ya
beaucoup de
d'allégations il ya beaucoup de
présomptions si vous voulez mais pas de
preuve alors nous on demande deux choses
on demande la transparence du rapport de
l'olaf concernant ce commissaire dany et
l'attention personnelle personne n'a eue
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'on demande
à monsieur baroin de s'expliquer parce
que nos parlementaires on a voté le
candidat monsieur dali et lorsque on ne
démissionne on n'a pas eu de compte
rendu de la part de monsieur barroso
donc on veut des explications claires
pourquoi il a fait démissionner quelles
sont les preuves qui ont fait que
monsieur dali et démissionner parce que
moi la question que je me pose c'est à
qui profite le crime vient pour
l'instant le cri profite à l'industrie
du tabac puisqu'il y avait une directive
du tabac qui était dans les tuyaux et
qui a été bloqué par le fait de la
démission du socialiste donc vous pensez
comme le principal intéressé d'ailleurs
john dalli parce que c'est ce qu'il dit
que finalement il aurait été victime des
industriels du tabac alors écoutez je
n'ai pas l'épreuve mais je me dis que
c'est quand même bizarre que malte est
un petit pays ont dit à dali de partir
comme ça on n'a pas de preuves pour dire
qu'il a fait une faute exemplaire qui
fait qu' on a démissionné imaginez que
ça soit mis sur route inger commissaire
allemand où monsieur barnier commissaire
et représentant la france je veux dire
ça aurait fait un scandale donc ce que
j'aime pas c'est qu'on a on nous a
jamais donné une explication tangible
sur la démission de m alors après les
ogm est un autre sujet qui est très
concernant pour nous tous c'est celui
des téléphones portables au moins
d'octobre en italie il ya eu pour la
première fois en europe la cour de
cassation qui a reconnu qu'un homme qui
s'appelle inocente
pollini a été victime d'une tumeur dual
usage intensif du téléphone portable on
va en parler dans un instant avec vous
mais d'abord on écoute ce matériau
j'ai une douleur constante
24 heures sur 24
ici dans cette partie
je crois que les téléphones portables
entre dans la liste des dangers
potentiels qui sont la cause des tumeurs
cérébrales les téléphones sont
probablement les instruments les plus
polluants que l'on utilise à cause de la
proximité de l'appareil lors de
l'utilisation
il y a de plus en plus de tumeurs
cérébrales en particulier les tumeurs
malignes qui se produisent suite à
l'utilisation des téléphones portables
et les tumeurs augmente chez les jeunes
voilà pour cette interview dinnosanté
marcolini avec quelques officiels
italiens des interviews recueillies par
la rai est-ce que vous deviez que sur
les téléphones portables
on risquerait d'aller dans un scandale
qui serait proche par exemple de celui
de l'amiante mais écoutez il ya plein
indices qui montrent que l'utilisation
intensive du téléphone portable est le
cas de monsieur marcolini est exemplaire
montrent qu'il ya bien une une relation
de cause à effet alors une présomption
de preuves entre le fait d'utiliser
massivement son portable et d'avoir une
tumeur au cerveau moi ce que je condamne
c'est que les opérateurs et les
politiques notre l'opérateur de
téléphonie de téléphonie mobile ne font
pas une information pour dire aux
consommateurs
attention le portable c'est pas un objet
banal c'est un objet à risque plus on
l'utilisé plus vous avez des ddd risque
de déclencher un cancer et notamment au
niveau des enfants il va y avoir la
période de noël il faut pas que les
mamans parce qu'elles sont anxieuses
achète un portable à leurs enfants plus
on est jeune plus il ya des risques de
déclencher des pensées si vous voulez il
ya tellement de milliards
véhiculée par les opérateurs téléphonie
mobile que on nie complètement les
risques et d'activer l'acm j'ai envie de
dire on est un petit peu comme sur les
les ogm il ya eu des études qui ont été
faites maintenant d'un certain recul
puisque le téléphone portable existe
depuis une vingtaine d'années et aucune
de ces études n'a dit clairement que le
danger était présent alors écoutez il ya
une étude qui s'appelle l'étude
bioinitiative qualité publiés par
l'agencé européenne de l'environnement
et qui montre les risques les ai fait
qui montre qu'un pad rit souvent elles
sont financées par les opérateurs mais
c'est comme l'histoire des ogm il ya
énormément de conflit d'intérêts moi
toutes les études y ait eu plus de 1500
étude publiée par l' agence européenne
qui montrent que via des risques au
niveau du cerveau il ya des risques
hormonaux il ya des risques au niveau de
l'adn alors il faut comme les morts
voyez l'amiante c'était la même chose il
y avait un comité permanent où il y
avait plus de
d'industriels avec des experts financées
par les industriels que deux médecins
capables de le dénoncer et ben on est
dans le même cas de figure donc
l'exemple de ceux de monsieur marc
politique est un cadre qui utilisait son
portable par rapport à sa profession et
bien cette personne a développé une
tumeur et ce qui est important c'est que
là le responsable c'est l'opérateur
téléphonie mobile et moi je lance un cri
de 2 g de dire et de l'information au
niveau de la population française en
disant attention n'achetez pas de
portable pour vos enfants dites à vos
ados d'utiliser le sms prenez un kit
oreillette mais ne pensez pas que le
portable c'est un objet banal qu'on met
facilement au niveau du cerveau au delà
de l'information évidemment qui est qui
est importante si le téléphone portable
est ici dangereux que que vous le dites
ça veut dire que il va y avoir des
centaines peut-être des milliers voire
plus de personnes qui vont développer
des tumeurs est-ce que vous avez une
possibilité d'action j'ai envie de dire
au parlement européen et vous en
particulier qui serait par exemple du
domaine légal alors ce que je fais sur
le parlement européen c'est de dire un
il ya une recommandation européenne
qu'il faut il faut réduire les champs
électromagnétiques parce qu'ils sont
beaucoup trop hauts et qu'en plus il
faut reconnaître
l'électrohypersensibilité il faut
réduire au niveau de chaque état membre
si vous voulez et chante parce que y'a
le portable mais il ya aussi les
antennes relais et les ondes de la
téléphonie mobile c'est des ondes
pulsées qui ont un effet sanitaire plus
important que les autres par exemple de
la télévision ou
des relais au niveau de la radio donc
c'est vraiment je suis en train de
pousser le parlement européen et la
commission pour que elle légifère et qui
est une harmonisation sur le plan
européen ce qui n'est pas le cas mais en
même temps il faut faire l'information
au niveau des consommateurs
michèle rivasi merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation va rester
évidemment dans le domaine européen et
nous allons parler de l'illettrisme en
europe dans quelques instants kathia
gilder en parlera avec son invité mais
nous allons tout de suite partir au
portugal en fait il ya en europe 75
millions de personnes qui sont victimes
d'illettrisme et au portugal c'est assez
marquée puisque dans ce pays et bien
c'est 10 % de plus que la moyenne
européenne regardez ce reportage
il est signé sandra cerqueira
écrire un geste familier que certains
dans l'enfance n'ont jamais vraiment
apprivoiser nous sommes dans ce qu'on
appelle au portugal un centre des
nouvelles opportunités créé avec le
soutien du fonds social européen des
cours du soir pour remettre à niveau
ceux qui ont quitté l'école trop tôt la
plupart dans cette place ils sont restés
moins de 6 ans certaines marges j'ai
grandi dans une famille de sept enfants
les frères ne sont allés à l'école
primaire et mon père m'a dit que même si
j'étais le plus jeune je ne pouvais pas
étudié plus qu'un coup mais ils ont
entre 40 et 50 ans et réapprennent
aujourd'hui ce qui nous semble à tous
être des acquis au portugal 72 % des
actifs n'ont pas fréquenté le secondaire
j'ai arrêté l'école à 12 ans il y avait
un trop grand fossé entre moi et les
jeunes générations y compris avec mes
filles j'étais dépassé par les
connaissances actuelles et j'ai ressenti
le besoin de reprendre les études et une
telle tâche plus simple certains
rencontrent des difficultés au début
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les connaissances
de base suffisante
ils ont perdu l'habitude d'écrire et de
lire la moitié de la population active
du pays a quitté l'école à 14 15 ans
en trois ans la fréquentation du centre
a doublé louise vient d'arriver pour
constituer un dossier et suivre des
cours il a commencé à travailler à 14
ans dans la vente aujourd'hui au chômage
il ne pensait pas qu'un jour le manque
d'études serait un handicap waouh
il y a deux ans j'ai perdu un emploi
parce que je n'étais même pas aller au
collège
ces adultes qui arrivent ici ont tous
entre 40 50 ans
ils ont travaillé dans la même
entreprise depuis qu'ils sont tout
jeunes et quand ils se retrouvent au
chômage
ils ont de l'expérience certes mais le
manque de qualification
leur est vraiment fatale
d'emblée ils sont exclus du marché du
travail
le portugal mauvais élèves de l'europe
mais dans le reste de l'union aussi lire
et écrire sans peine n'est pas une
évidence un tiers de la population
active est peu ou pas qualifiés et
concernant les plus jeunes générations
les chiffres ne sont guère meilleures
20% des jeunes sortent de l'école sans
avoir acquis le niveau de compétence
minimum le portugal connaît là encore le
taux le plus élevé d'europe 30%
d'abandon scolaire chez les jeunes
dans cette école de la deuxième chance
la seule du pays les élèves n'ont pas
étudié plus que leurs parents quand ils
arrivent ici ils ont arrêté les cours
depuis de nombreuses années
chaque jour paulo participent aux cours
de cuisine pour réapprendre à travailler
en groupe ils préparent ensemble le
déjeuner pour toute l'école il a 23 ans
et n'est même pas allé au collège c'est
pour travailler et aider sa famille
qu'il ait décidé d'arrêter les études
l'école envoyé des lettres à mes parents
pour dire j'y allais plus mais ça n'a
servi à rien depuis j'ai cherché du
travail
je n'ai rien trouvé je pensais que
d'arrêter l'école à 15 ans mme
empêcherait pas de travailler dans la
restauration
souvent les jeunes portugais décroche
faute d'encadrement familial c'est
l'héritage de la dictature salazariste
qui négligea pendant 40 ans l'éducation
des masses
ici on est plus que des formateurs on
remplace la famille les parents quitté
licol six jeunes favorise l'exclusion
sociale on leur apprend à retrouver un
cadre c'est important pour eux pour la
suite
faute de moyens l'école a failli fermer
l'an passé le directeur se dit inquiet
car les demandes d'inscription ne cesse
d'augmenter
le portugal est dans une situation
économique très difficile
de toute façon on ne peut pas se passer
de cette jeune génération parce que nous
avons l'une des populations les plus
vieillissante d'oran
incontestablement l'illettrisme est une
entrave à la croissance un vrai handicap
pour la compétitivité le pays doit faire
les efforts nécessaires pour que les
qualifications augmente nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix
d'autant que le pays possède également
le taux de scolarisation dans le
supérieur le plus faible de l'union
européenne pourtant dans dix ans
seulement 15% des emplois seront
destinés aux basses qualification
retour à bruxelles nous sommes avec
karima delli bonjour je députée
européenne et vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires sociales et de
l'emploi et vous travaillé notamment sur
la question de l'exclusion est-ce que ce
que l'on a vu dans ce reportage la
réalité de ces personnes en situation
d'illettrisme vous étonne au des
situations au qu'au coeur de l'europe au
portugal
or cette situation ne m'étonne pas ce
que je connais le sujet et c'est là le
drame c'est à dire que la question de
l'illettrisme aujourd'hui devenue une
question taboue pour les états alors
qu'elle devrait être une priorité
politique on ne peut pas laisser en
europe 75 millions de personnes qui sont
notamment dans cette situation
d'illettrisme ça fait presque un
européen sur cinq ça fait 1 européen sur
sept et quand on regarde les chiffres
notamment des jeunes ça ça explose ce
n'est pas normal qu'on laisse 13 % des
15-24 ans sans aucun ni empoigne
apprentissage sans aucune formation qui
justes permettent d'avoir les éléments
de la vie parce que ce que vous dites
est ce que tu dis très bien votre
reportage c'est qu'aujourd'hui il lit
les tris aura des conséquences terribles
elles seront terribles sur l'emploi
parce que malheureusement aujourd'hui si
nous n'avons pas de bonnes bases de
qualification on a des réponses
répercussions sur l'emploi et surtout
l'illétrisme et moi je me je travaille
beaucoup sur l'exclusion et la pauvreté
a une conséquence directe sur les
questions de pauvreté alors on va juste
préciser l'illettrisme c'est le fait de
ne pas maîtriser des connaissances de
base lire écrire compter des
connaissances qui permet d'être autonome
dans la dans la vie quotidienne ce qui
est différent de l'analphabétisme quels
sont pour vous les causes de ce
phénomène un peu un peu caché finalement
est-ce qu'on a honte parfois de dire
qu'on est illettrée quelles sont les
causes est ce que c'est du un échec
scolaire est ce que c'est c'est dû à un
problème de formation qui responsable
vous ça je pense que d'abord c'est
l'ensemble des politiques publiques donc
des états qui sont responsables parce
qu'on a laissé
justement sous le tapis cette cette
question qui devrait être prioritaire ça
c'est la première chose dit qu'il
devrait pas y avoir d'illettrés dans les
pays européens en devrait justement
lutter contre ce fléau et pour ça il
faut en faire une priorité la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il a fallu attendre
jusque septembre pour avoir un rapport
de l'ensemble est le constat qui accable
malheureusement l'europe sur ces
thématiques là aujourd'hui la véritable
question c'est de dire nous ne pouvons
plus aujourd'hui réellement
juste des déclarations il faut des actes
alors qu'elle a justement vous qui êtes
députée européenne qui travailler sur le
terrain qui rencontraient des acteurs
qu'elle quel type d'action faut-il
engagé à quel niveau haut niveau alors
c'est à dire il faut faire au niveau
européen au niveau national comme au
niveau local ces trois niveaux sont
nécessaires d'une part il faut et le
reportage le dit bien il faut aider les
parents aider les parents pour que eux
mêmes ont les compétences pour qu'il
donne envie alors enceinte de moulins z
eh bien on peut mettre en place
notamment par exemple des structures qui
permettent
d'apprendre à lire et à écrire parce que
justement aujourd'hui si vous ne savez
pas lire ni écrire pour trouver un
emploi pour faire vos courses pour payer
une facture c'est tout est difficile
vous n'êtes plus autonomes ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose qu'il
faut renforcer c'est réellement
l'accompagnement social des enfants
notamment renforcé des petits groupes
pour que justement ils prennent le temps
qu'ils qui font en sorte d'améliorer
leurs compétences ça c'est la deuxième
chose est la troisième chose vraiment
qui moi me paraît important c'est
d'utiliser les fonds européens qui sont
souvent mal utilisés pour faire
notamment des
une véritable qualification un
apprentissage pour l'ensemble des ces
jeunes qui sortent justement de ces
systèmes scolaires sans rien c'est
souhaitable mais dans l'immédiat ce
qu'on constate c'est que passante qu'on
a vu au portugal le type d'action qui
émeut des dents dans ce centre qui aide
les personnes illettrées à retrouver des
connaissances
qui leur permettront d'être autonome on
a vu que ce centre il était financé en
partie par le fonds social européen or
celui ci est quand même menacé de
disparition ou en tout cas menacé d'être
réduit à peau de chagrin vu que les
états
ne se sont pas mis d'accord sur le
budget européen est ce que ce fonds est
menacé alors ce fonds est menacée quand
l'ensemble des fonds européens mais le
parlement européen a est en codécision
et le parlement européen dit clairement
nous mettrons nos bêtes notre veto si
l'ensemble des chefs d'état décident
demain de réduire à peau de chagrin
justement notamment le fonds social pour
le clairement pour refuser que ce type
de fonds soient réduits il a va la
revoir là comme il le fait par exemple
sur les aides alimentaires ou nous
refusons justement une réduction
aujourd'hui le but c'est de dire il faut
comprendre que les politiques sociales
ce sont des investissements se sont pas
des dépenses nous le parlement européen
ne comprenons que la lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'exclusion dont
l'illettrisme est reparti est une
priorité alors justement il ya des
acteurs qui comptent votre action nous
avons rencontré une personne pour notre
reportage au portugal qui a une question
directe à vous poser une question qui
s'adresse à l'élue européenne que vous
êtes écouter
il est juste on avait été ballot europe
s'est fixé comme objectif de réduire
d'ici 2020 à moins de 15% la part des
jeunes n'ayant pas qui le niveau de
compétence minimum alors je demande
franchement responsables européens
qu'êtes vous réellement disposé à faire
quand on sait que pour atteindre cet
objectif il faut aider les pays les plus
touchés par la crise et ce sont ces pays
qui n'ont pas les moyens d' éradiquer
l'illettrisme
ils ont besoin d'être pour cela
alors comment les aider alors tout
simplement notamment combattre
concernant les jeunes aujourd'hui même
on va mettre en place une garantie
jeunesse qui va obligatoirement inciter
les états à dire qu'aucun jeunes sans
formation sans qui sortent du système
scolaire on doit au bout de quatre mois
lui proposer quelque chose nous dit on
c'est le parlement européen
c'est la commission et le parlement
européen qui demande aux états que les
états s'engagent au bout de quatre mois
à apporter notamment à chaque jeune soit
une formation ou un emploi son offre
hostile ce sera là dans quelques dans
quelques jours c'est ce qu'on appelle la
garantie genève on parle des jeunes il
ya aussi des personnes on les a vus dans
ce reportage qui ont plus de 50 ans qui
sont moins jeunes en tout cas et qui ont
du mal à garder un travail oit trouver
un travail qu'est-ce qu'on peut offrir
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez offrir comme
perspective comme travail à cette
population là qui parfois et même
souvent et peu qualifiés alors tu
d'abord vous avez dit peu qualifiés il
faut savoir que l'ensemble des personnes
peu qualifiées en europe comme en france
sont exclus du du marché du travail ça
il faut tirer la sonnette d'alarmé parce
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque vous êtes par
exemple non diplômés au chômage ça
représente 15% alors que quand vous êtes
diplômé c'est seulement 5% ce qu'on peut
les aider alors le chemin
l'emploi alors que pour ça il faut d'une
part les accompagner mais surtout
renforcer le dispositif notamment deux
formations pour ça ce n'est pas normal
par exemple coffrante 10 % des chômeurs
n'ont pas accès à une formation
notamment au pôle emploi parce que soit
ils n'ont pas la formation soit ils
n'ont pas réellement une formation qui
leur correspond où ça ce n'est pas une
formation d'avenir par soit ils ne
savent pas que tel type de dispositifs
existent voilà où alors on n'y a pas
d'information accessible contrairement à
nos voisins européens et ensuite
lorsqu'on parle de formation aujourd'hui
il faut investir dans des nouveaux
secteurs on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
regardez le passé le monde a changé et
ces secteurs les secteurs d'avenir c'est
ça c'est ce que moi j'appelle les
secteurs les éco-industries parce que
souvent on a tendance à croire que
l'industrie est le la est en panique à
un exemple pour pour fermer sur un
exemple de secteur d'avenir porteur
l'agriculture d'espoir pour ces
personnes par exemple l'agriculture
biologique aujourd'hui ce sont des
emplois locaux non délocalisables qui
vont permettre réellement
d'engranger des milliers d'emplois un
autre secteur c'est la rénovation
thermique aujourd'hui il va falloir
rénové par exemple en france des
millions de logements nous aurons besoin
de me de d'emplois qualifiés est
également peu qualifiés c'est bon pour
climat c'est bon pouvoir d'achat c'est
pas bon cours pour l'emploi local voilà
bien merci le message bien compris merci
d'avoir été avec nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à strasbourg avec nora
hamadi pour une nouvelle édition
d'europe et d'autres très bonne semaine
à tous ciao